Let's look at the inverse of linear functions. We're going to find the inverse
function of f of x equals 2 x plus 3. We've seen functions like these before.
This is just a linear equation that crosses the y axis at 0, 3 since the y
receptor's 3. The slope of this equation is 2, so we'll rise 2 and then we'll
move to the right one unit. Now this is all the way back to unit three when we
first learned about lines. But now what we're going to do is we're going to
undo these operations. We know f of x is the same thing as y. This is just the
output. So, now, the first thing we need to do to find the inverse function is
to switch x and y. If we switch the variables x and y, then we get this new
equation. X equal 2 y plus 3. Now we just need to solve for y to get our new
inverse function. so you tell me, what would you get for y if you solved for
it? In other words, what's the expression over here that involves x? As a hint,
it should be a fraction.